So we are right
in the middle of our network meeting.
All this wonderful people came here
to talk with us about Berlin
Science Week and to get to know each other
and us as a team.
And this is a continuation
from our information session this morning,
which we held online and now really happy
to have everybody here
with us in the office.
I definitely recommend
joining Berlin Science Week
so you can grab different ideas.
You could have a great exchange
with mind blowing
experts because
for renewed scientists in the field
and also just visitors who could inspire
you with their questions.
It is not just about science,
but about the way science is communicated,
which is usually what scientists are
struggling with because it's very nice.
Yes, to do science,
but it's also very nice to be able
to communicate it to the general public.
Well, in Science Week is a great space
to make networking between researchers
of different parts of the world.
And we open the doors
of the Mexican embassy.
For those that are interested
in knowing the results of the cooperation
of the scientific relation
between Mexico and Germany.
It's always important to bring societies,
science and art together.
Yeah.
Looking for a good co-creation.
We are also discussing whether we could
actually extend our partnership
into more creative
exploring ways of bringing arts
and science communities together.
We just collecting the program right now.
We have already quite some submissions,
but still more to come,
hopefully from all of you.
So please talk to us.